[Música]
ranking siete menos uno más personas
ebrias pensé que no tomaríamos más 1 2
y si comenzamos haciendo unas
presentaciones cortas ella es kennedy
ella es de los ángeles y tiene 25 este
sprays es de nueva jersey y también
tiene 25
y tengo 23
soy yo que tengo 41 y soy de la costa me
llamo gay tengo 22 y soy de
massachusetts soy cat tengo 24 y soy
alérgica a la zarza olalia no quiero que
sepan donde vivo no tienes que utilizar
la dirección
y el código pues que creen ustedes que
estarán buscando en los demás la forma
de expresión es lo que me fijaba en sus
tonos de piel si se estaban sonrojando o
no si estaban siendo más ruidosos
animados caminar derecho
puede hablar bien grace enséñanos camina
derecho vamos a hacerlo al revés hay que
caminar como policías
genial
[Risas]
es una pasarela
para estas cosas
directo a la cárcel
toda mi vida para esto
y puntalón punto
natural
vamos a darle a darnos palmas
[Aplausos]
vamos adelante
porque eres el más confiado así no
funcionan reyes la referencia se coloca
en el medio y a partir de eso nos
ubicamos en el medio
como ni siquiera estoy ahí toda la
prefiesta y la prefiesta estoy en la
lista más deberíamos comenzar desde
arriba hacia abajo mejor muy bien si es
más
debemos encontrar una manera de evaluar
esto juntemos es que está decididos
creo que tenemos que
es
el
destino
en el medio si le soy muy de acuerdo
me siento aquí arriba pero siento como
si no creo que
mi vida creo que yo debo estar
tal vez ahora
bien de acuerdo esperen lo que tengo la
solución tengo la solución bueno qué tan
seguido bebés nunca vienen lo que bebe
qué tan seguido bebés mi novia es barman
así que lo ha conseguido muy bien ver
25 años dos veces por semana qué tan
seguido bebés
una vez al día
todos los días
de acuerdo yo vemos puede que una vez ha
escrito ido me creo que se confirma el
sitio en el que estás ahora acaso el el
que se basa como en tu peso y altura se
basa en tu peso y tenemos que sacarlos
primero
no hay modo de que este chico esté más
obvio que yo ni de broma te quiero pero
lo que debemos tomar decisiones
importantes os quiero pero no lo
es
[Música]
tiene sentido que me equivoqué
que todos tienen razón y así es dijeron
que vas a y es su decisión
tenemos lágrimas nos vemos en lugares
que consideran correcta la forma de que
no
[Música]
están listos sí hagámoslo respira
profundo
[Música]
i
[Aplausos]
[Música]
punto 52 se los digo sabía que estaba
mal
la sopla
[Música]
ya está bien bien lo tenemos o no quiero
de 51 casi exactamente lo mismo sopla
sopla sopla
punto 56
va a estar tan nuestra
lo hemos hecho bien hasta ahorita te
justo a inhalar ya cuenta regresiva y
espera que llegue a cero y ustedes
trabajen pero van a tener un gran día
con esto
cuanto sacaste punto 57 demonios digo
mejor felicidad
no tenemos
0.57 hasta ahora todo bien
punto 53
esto es lo que todos esperábamos yo solo
diré que apuesto que no hacerlo sola
price sólo eso aplastante
[Aplausos]
lo hice
apuesto siete puntos
7.71
la cantidad exacta hoy cambiamos estamos
parís
tu eres una persona
al frente
sí
estoy tan confundida tomás y entonces
perdimos en una hora
está de más decir que bryce no es un
consumidor de alcohol experimentado
siempre supe que bryce ser el más ebrio
él tenía un comportamiento sin
inhibiciones así que quieres darme tu
opinión opinión yo no pensaba que era el
más ebrio y resulta que lo era y eso
está bien
[Música]